alla fine di ragazzi permettere una clip
bonus di valencia che non era ancora
uscito sul canale per adesso volete
vivido buona visione
bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo momento sono fan i geni oggi
siamo su bon bon che dovrebbe essere un
gioco horror perché tra dal nome non
sembra mai nella vita mustard la
partenza di è che horror quanto basta
c'è un cane intagliato al legno mi più
brutto che abbia mai visto
ma gay tasto sinistro dai al bob lee
dong bush grande gioco dell'anno raga io
sono un bambino veramente è da una vita
che sognavo di fare questa cosa e adesso
la farò perfetto ciao mamma invisibile
adesso porto tutto dentro promesso
lancia baum siro per ruota bouncy o per
chi ciao bansi hoffer
ma che cosa mettono esattamente negli
omogenizzati al giorno d'oggi devo
portare le palle all'interno della casa
perché mia mamma me l'ha ordinato
ovviamente la fa entra in casa maledetta
palla no vabbè tanto troviamo un altro
che sono tre le palle
ecco affetto dai la palla rosa poi
vabbè se gli omogeneizzati poi li
mangiano anche i topi è un casino siamo
a due
ok è l'ultima palla e ci siamo lo
portate mamma fammi entrare che c'è un
topo grasso trova una palla ancora ma
dove le ho trovate le palle mamma non
rompere troviamo le palle mamma ce l'hai
ancora il veleno per topi quello che usa
vi per il topino in cucina
ecco né ordini tre scatole da amazon
menu passi gentilmente visto che sei
alto sì c'è un po stronzo però guarda io
entro in casa però grazie per l'aiuto
sei stato molto gentile divertiti e con
i tuoi amici o roditori stupidi perfetto
comunque io ho visto ratatouille che era
un bel cartone però se il topo era
grosso così era un po un casino è prova
perché c'è una puntata di capello sul
televisore come e così anche tratta
cartoni mamma mia e il cartone più
brutto che abbia mai visto
fa vj mamma non mi piacciono questi
cartoni posso cambiare canale frutta e
mag si chiama sua mamma che brutti devo
mettere via i pupazzi ma basta ma sto
bambino qua passa la vita a mettere a
posto i giocattoli fammi capire o va
bene però mamma mia quanti giocattoli
cio in giro mamma mia non avrò mai un
figlio la smettiamo questo cartone arca
vacca tutti e quattro perfetto ma basta
quanti e robe se gioco costa 3 euro io
ho pagato 3 euro per raccogliere dei
giocattoli fatemi capire
sì sì è la purple monster dove l'altro
manca un cubo che ovviamente non trovo
eccolo qua in quella omogenizzato che
hai mangiato si sicuro che non ci fosse
una barretta di uranio dentro
no perché in tal caso c'è un problema io
vado che la mamma mi chiamano non posso
venire
mamma va a rispondere brava dio dove
sono scusami in tutto questo è il top
salve me l'ha presa mia mamma a questa
torta è buona è un sacco buona
attenzione a mangiare che potrebbe
esserci sì sì prendi prendi prego prego
fa con comodo come se fossi a casa tua
potresti usare il tuo vaiolo per
cortesia il tovagliolo grazie no non
sulla maglia vabbè levo in altro che mi
tieni se le dona altro tieni mangia che
devi crescere
ok piano piano che si sbricioli poi mi
ama mi fa un mazzo così piano l'aiuto
vaiolo siamo casa mia
siamo calmi che quanto a casa tua il
tovagliolo è dna buon appetito
perfetto sul 39 un'altra ma io comunque
mi sottratta re gli ospiti è questo su
questo non avete niente da dire è stai
calmo ora attimo non ci incavoliamo è
che quando siamo al ristorante non mi
paga nessuno ti sto offrendo il cibo
della mia tavola quindi ok madame
desidera un dessert un qualcosa sì ma
d'apice su feletto l cheescake seascape
ora le madame mama lese un problema
grosso molto grosso
basta e parla con l'amante che ci sta un
top grosso qua senti non ti puoi
mangiare tutta la mia torta il mio
compleanno po cosa me magno io scusa
l'altra non è tagliata e non sono capace
quindi da tali turno nov
basta bomb si chiama bom bom il tizio
meta meta torta di se magna io ma magna
ha tramandato non vedi che son magro è
ho bisogno io di questa torta no che se
mi mangio un po di corsa e poi torna a
mia madre tu sei sparito pensa che sono
un limbo obeso c'era un posto dai vai
via a un po fuori dalle bomba o fuori
basta non ti sei proprio comportare a
casa degli altri fai schifo vergogna
vergognati bomb vergognosi la vergogna è
stato bon bon
ma io l'ho visto ma come come ora di
andare in bagno ma non l'ha visto a mia
mamma mia madre non vede è difficile da
non vedere sto topo è a sono andato a
nanna sto dormendo ma che madre piga mi
mette un registratore per raccontarmi le
storie
beh io comunque ho speso 3 euro di gioco
per guardare un cartone guardare un topo
che mangia una torta e ascoltare delle
favole per favore io mio poi spegne
raccontami delle storie degli emo che si
tagliano grazie io sono stato 5 mi
perché poi ho tagliato ma sono cinque
minuti pieni ad ascoltare una fiaba che
cosa me ne frega della fiaba a me non
potevamo saltare direttamente a questa
parte dove sono in piedi nel mezzo della
notte e non si sa il perché era meglio
ma ho paura aprite una creatura pelosa
grossa è venuto a trovarmi ieri e non
sto parlando di nonna sta facendo qua
riti satanici quei giocattoli l obbligo
io piuttosto gioco mamma mia non so se
avete notato ma bob lee dog non ha più
le zampe poverino mobili dog per me
mamma ha invitato un po di amici
all'asilo spero non sia un problema
mobilità o che di nuovo le gambe sentivo
potresti fare un favore va in
avanscoperta vai a vedere cosa c'é vai
vai
avvertimi se trovi qualcosa è che brutta
a casa mamma mia sta a posto o blog
no non sei spiderman sei un cane
ricordatelo
ma non c'è niente di qua
bon bon bon bon guarda chi è trovato
aubrey dogg my baby doc fai giocare con
bon bon non mi fai del mare bonbon vero
perché ti ho fatto mangiare il pezzo di
torta ieri quando lardo ai stupido top
ma non avevo capito fosse un incubo ma
almeno non ci sono più le fiabe almeno
quello
ma la macchina questo non me l'aspettavo
questa me la aspettavo veramente escape
escape escape the lack veloci bonbon mi
far del male bubble bobble veloci qui
che bon bon e gross o non mi tocca a
beaumont che ti denuncio nasconditi vai
mamma mia che movimenti agi gaa questo
bambino è bonbon quello il mio letto
bomb non puoi stare sul mio letto non
puoi stare sul mio letto e poi un casino
ma cosa ai papà angelo
cos'è che ti magni davanti allo schermo
macchiette magni non è finito non va
buttato 3 euro così dai non ho veramente
buttato 3 euro così per cortesia adesso
mi fate capire perché cosa io ho buttato
4 euro del 34 amico lo monterà ma qua
c'è anche 50 centesimi sono buttati
qualcosa non va con bonbon fateci sapere
qui scrivono i programmatori c'è una
chat
ecco tutto pubblica commento perfetto
lascia la clip di valencia è così vicino
che ti prende male è un blog sta
bloccando con il mio phone
e quindi le riprese le faccio anche
anonimamente ma le piogge in società
può essere utilizzato anche come bello
che capiremo
no cosa se vi è piaciuto come mi piace
anche per bon bon che poverino se lo
merita anche varie che sia ci vediamo un
po seguito da ragazzi